if there's a war Taiwan shuts down who
depends more on ships made in Taiwan is
it us or is it China if there's one key
factor securing American economic
prosperity and Military superiority it's
not oil it's not even weapons it's chips
chips power everything from our military
Machinery to our smartphones that are
glued to our hands until recently the US
had dominance in crafting the fastest
chips in the world but countries like
Taiwan and more importantly China are
catching up fast this is technology that
everyone uses but it's technology that
governments have played a major role in
shaping this unfolding race will
determine our future and it's been
thoroughly chronicled by today's
exceptionally interesting guest Chris
Miller in his book aptly titled Chip War
Chris is a professor of international
history with a focus on the Cold War
he's devoted much of his life to the
study let's get into it everybody out
there welcome to a very very special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast requested by my brother-in-law
because he loves this book uh by Chris
Miller called Chip War so we're going to
go to war today we're going to talk
about this wonderful really incredible
runaway bestseller of 2023 by Chris
Miller or maybe it came out in 2022 did
it come out in 22 or 23 that's right
late 2022 late 2022 okay it's been a
year of just uh accolades and uh encomia
from all over the world and we're going
to get into deep deep dive into the
technology into the physics you know
Chris you I might be the first person
that you've ever talked to on a podcast
that's actually done lithography that's
made actual semiconductor and
superconduct these are superconducting
detectors we used in my bicep experiment
this is a lithograph uh Proto protoc
circuit for an antenna that we used in
the polar bear 2 experiment which is
ongoing in the AMA desert we're going to
talk about defraction lithography some
of cool stuff being done here in San
Diego and in Europe but first we're
going to do what you're never ever under
any circumstance supposed to do which is
to judge a book by its cover especially
one as delightful as this now we're
going to hold up a fake book I'm gonna
hold up my my iPhone that has you know I
listen to the book on audiobook form
Chris tell us what was the Genesis the
origin of the wonderful cover and the
title especially the subtitle of your
fabulous new book the title Chip War uh
emerged actually it wasn't my my first
choice for title it emerged after
discussions with my editor who was
brilliant I think at at encapsulating a
book's argument I was initially actually
planning to call the book the switch
with a reference to transistors turning
circuits on and off but uh my editor
said no that that doesn't get the thesis
of the book and the thesis is about the
contest for controlling uh this
technology and indeed one of the the
themes that emerged from the research
was the role of the defense industrial
base in pushing forward semiconductor
technology and so that's how we settled
on Chip War uh referencing the the
military Origins but also the battle
between companies and countries uh for
this technology and so the cover at
least the US cover the international
additions all different covers but the
US cover has an American flag juxtaposed
next to a semiconductor which speaks to
the fact that this is technology that
everyone uses but it's technology that
governments have played a major role in
shaping its development and the uh
International copy uh that I saw is a of
of a globe or a map or something like
that that's right yeah it's a a picture
of a globe with kind of circuit tree
carved into it yes and this was uh very
reminiscent that's why I brought my own
circuit board here uh reminiscent of uh
of what we do in the laboratory and and
what we how we use these sensors and I
want to take us back to maybe the OG of
of all things uh digital switches as you
mentioned transistors uh and that is of
course none other than Gordon Moore uh
who passed away not too long ago uh
sadly because he was an incredible
supporter not just of applied science
but of basic science pure research I
want to get into that with you but I
want to H get your reaction to this
quote from Gordon Moore he said
allegedly he said if the automobile
industry had set a pace similar to that
of the semiconductor industry a
Rolls-Royce would get a half a million
miles per gallon and it would be cheaper
to throw it away than to park it is that
still true Chris are we still are we
still progressing at a rate anticipated
by Moore's Law even if the exponent has
changed or the or the base period has
changed pretty much there's there's
different ways you can you can def uh
Define and assess Moore's law but the
basic intuition that we're getting
dramatically more computing power every
couple of years at dramatically reduced
cost holds true which is why you can go
on Amazon and buy a thumb drive with a
billion transistors uh for not that much
money that would have been Unthinkable
not just 50 years ago but 30 years ago
20 years ago that was a mind-bogglingly
large number and that still basically
holds uh which is why everyone is racing
to get their hands on the Next
Generation Nvidia chips to train bigger
and bigger AI systems is because the
next generation is better and better at
a really extraordinary rate and I think
if you think of the rest of the economy
the rest of society the rest of
Technology nothing else comes close to
that sustained rate of improvement over
time the only thing that really Compares
is is the the cost and speed of Gene
sequencing which has fallen really
dramatically the past couple of decades
but Mo's law has been in operation now
for over half a and it's really
unparalleled in all of human history hey
fellow wanders into the impossible I
hope this deep dive into the
semiconductor world is as fascinating to
you as it was to me but there's an
important conversation to be had that
goes deep Beyond this and I want you to
be a part of it so please do me the
favor of subscribing to the channel and
or following it if you're listening on
audio platforms and for extra credit
homework give me a thumbs up review like
comment share it really helps with the
algorithm that these comp computer chips
are running in the background to really
boost our mission to connect millions of
Minds around the world of stem science
technology engineering and math and by
doing so you'll help me help you get the
greatest possible guest un into the
impossible now back to the episode of
Chris yeah and the um the connection
between Gene sequencing and also the uh
the microchip and semiconductor
Revolution uh is really highlighted as
well especially here in San Diego we
have alumina and I just interviewed
Craig bner uh who is a ventor who's the
uh uh one of the I I would say I say he
did sequence the human Geno as team did
it and kind of shared the credit with uh
Francis Collins and their team at NIH
but uh we had a rockus interview live in
person here and and he talked about you
know the foundational assets of having
computing power you know that was really
unrivaled and how that dominate allowed
them to dominate I want to take us to
the kind of Mythology and some of it
mentioned in the book and I I didn't
know if you I don't know if you know
this but uh here in San Diego we have
one of the founding fathers of the
transistor revolution in fact the Nobel
Prize winner uh who uh Co you know
shared the Nobel Prize for the invention
of the transistor we we don't have his
body but we apparently have some of his
um I'll say genetic material here and
what's called the Genius Factory or
perhaps the repository for germinal
Choice also known as the Nobel Prize
sperm bank and uh Shockley is a
character in this book obviously uh talk
about him I find him very fascinating uh
of course he was a genius uh inventor
although he may not have been as bright
allegedly he he kind of failed this this
termin study of uh of IQ by Noel
laurates but but uh tell me about
Shockley and his role and this mythology
that we have of putting these you know
kind of contributors to the technology
Revolution up on a pedestal whether
financially or intellectually well shaky
certainly was an important figure in the
development of some of the the theory as
well as some of the initial inventions
that led to the first transistor and
then the ability to produced them at
larger scale uh but he's also I think a
great case study in how if people are
focused on getting attention and getting
taking credit for inventions they can
write the history in a way uh that gives
him an outsized role and so he was
actually one of three scientists that
devised the first transistor um at Bell
Labs uh he actually didn't play the
major role in devising it he played the
major role in theorizing it but there's
a very famous photo that was taken right
when the first transistor was being
announced and he he put himself at the
center of the photo looking through the
microscope and had his two colleagues
standing behind him as though they were
his lab AIDS and and so he's gotten the
line share of the credit for the The
Invention but you know I think what's
interesting about shle is that although
the history is generally written with
him at the center in fact he was a a
failed business person he tried to mass
produce transistors couldn't do it h and
it was people like Gordon Moore who
turned the transistor from an
interesting science experiment into a
mass Market product and so if you want
to look at the technology Trend it's
it's actually less about the the
scientists who invented it and more
about the person uh the people who
learned how to mass produce them here at
UC San Diego we had uh two graduates of
our a university uh that was uh that
went on to found incredible business
here called Simer and that's Robert
Akens and Richard sandstrom um talk
about and now they're part of a asml and
you talk a lot about asml in the book
and and how crucial and really
monopolistic uh and hopefully
benevolently holistically so talk about
amsl and what is so fascinating to you
as a as a you know not not a physicist
but um but as as a writer as a as a
technologist talk about what fascinates
you so much about the the technology
used in this Exquisite production of
semiconductors that drive the modern
world asml is company that makes the
tools that make chips or makes some of
the tools that you need to make a
Cutting Edge uh chip and so its job is
is to produce these machines that can
manipulate materials at almost the
atomic level do so at a cost and at
volume uh that is financially viable
that's actually the hard part the hard
part is not the physics Al it's very
very very hard hard part is doing the
physics in a way that is viable to mass
production and so asml um was has been
involved in the lithography industry for
now around half a century but in the
early 1990s when this new type of
lithography called euv Extreme
ultraviolet was being invented asml was
the only company willing to bet that you
could commercialize this technology and
turn it into a a mass production product
as they spent three decades billions of
dollars uh took on huge financial and
Technical risk uh to produce these
machines and today they're the most
complex machines humans have ever made
they've got inside of them the flattest
mirrors ever made one of the strongest
lasers ever deployed in a commercial
device and an explosion happening inside
of the the chamber that Simer developed
that at a temperature of 40 or 50 times
the temperature of the surface of the
Sun and this isn't a one-off this is a
machine that works 24 hours a day at
seven days a week 365 days a year and it
has to work because each one of them
cost $150 million a piece so it's an
extraordinary combination of on the one
hand physics and Engineering the other
hand making it match the the business
case that's necessary to produce them by
the by the dozens and eventually by the
hundreds hey there fellow Warriors as we
prepare for our chip war with our
fantastic asked Chris Miller let's make
sure we're fully equipped for battle
building computer chips is a highly
specialized and complex task that
requires a combination of skills and
knowledge from various Fields like
computer science electrical engineering
and other fields fortunately with
brilliant acquiring these skills is just
a few clicks away brilliant is a dynamic
and interactive platform effective for
Hands-On learning it empowers you to
learn at your own pace and approach
problems like a real scientist does and
the best part it tailors content to your
unique learning styles and offers guided
bite-sized lessons to help you master
Concepts in just 15 minutes a day with
brilliant you'll gain the knowledge and
skills you need to venture into the chip
industry one of the most promising
career Fields right now ready to take
the first step check out their thinking
and code course to lay a strong
foundation for computational problem
solving Paving the way for their more
advanced computer science and
programming classes can do it on the run
on the app as I love to do every day or
even on the web to try everything
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org drbryan
keing or click on the link in the
description below the first 200 of you
will get 20% off brilliant's annual
premium subscription now back to the
battle As We join the Chip War let's go
and talk about the the challenges of
scaling up I mean you talk about the
feature size uh on these on these
exquisitely manufactured devices uh you
know this this one here you could do in
a uh literally in a with with Optical
light and and so forth they don't need
extreme ultraviolet uh Advanced uh
defraction gradings and and so forth but
talk about limitations the size scale is
approaching you know fractions of a
Corona virus you know for scale I love
that that's become a a figure of scale
nowadays uh tell me what are some of the
challenges of going Beyond these already
literally microscopic and Beyond
microscopic levels you know I think one
of the things that surprised me was that
to make smaller and smaller devices and
and as you say that the transistors in
the chips on our phones and in PCS are
now virus sized you need bigger and
bigger machines and bigger and bigger
and more complex Supply chains so when
the chip industry was founded uh
companies would do everything themselves
they'd make their own uh production
machines they'd refine their own
chemicals they' produce their own
silicon Wafers they try to do it all
whereas today every step is so
mind-bogglingly complex and the level of
specificity and purification and
precision is so high that there's not a
single company that can do anything on
their own and so the the number of firms
the number of countries involved in
making a chip inside your smartphone uh
now measures uh uh vastly larger than it
would have in the past and just the
machines themselves take a Cutting Edge
lithography machine they require
multiple airplanes to move because
they're so large and then the next
Generation lithography machine that will
make even smaller circuitry will be
substantially larger because to make
smaller and smaller devices you need
bigger and bigger machines and quote
that I also want to get your reaction to
goes like this what Gordon giveth Bill
taketh away that refers to Gordon Moore
Gordon Moore's Moors law but also Bill
Gates with Bill being a proxy for the
software you know the kind of voracious
appetite that software has to chew up
all these Computing resources in fact we
use um in our uh Cosmic uh data analysis
we use Department of energy machines
that are you know benchmarked top five
in the world or maybe even better
they're used primarily for new nuclear
fusion uh simulations and research in
nuclear weapons but they give us some
spare Cycles we found that at least I
found an and in formally talking to my
colleagues U Mo's law might keep
increasing but what I really care about
is how many papers you know come out of
it right I don't really care how many
flops are done I want to know how did
you distill this you know this
technology into floating front
operations that then do analysis on uh
the distribution of dark matter in the
universe for example that kind of
Benchmark you know the ultimate what
what I do is is convert money you know
into papers you know some funding agency
gives me a grant uh and we work and we
get a paper maybe we get 10 papers out
for every $10 million it's about a
million dollars of paper anyway
long-winded way of asking you is it not
true that the better the hardware gets
the software developers take advantage
of it or maybe don't and don't optimize
and so therefore Mor's law effect the
effective Mor's law for output which is
much you care about scientific discovery
Gene Discovery all sorts of protein
folding it's actually saturating and not
growing anywhere near the power law
exponent that mors law is so talk about
that the the bill taking away from what
Gordon gave us well you know I think
it's it's certainly true that we've got
a almost Limitless appetite for compute
uh and the more compute we get the less
efficient we have to be with it the less
compute cost the more incentive we have
to be inefficient because we can spend
our time on other things and so so it's
absolutely right that uh in times when
Moore's Law is improving at a rapid Pace
uh soft for engineers try less hard to
be efficient I would not agree with the
thesis that we're getting less Bay for
our block out of Mo's law I think you
know in certain spheres you can make
that argument but I guess when I look at
the explosion of interest and
applications of AI over just the past
couple of years it seems to me that
there's a lot of pretty fantastic
products coming down the pipeline and to
me that that's a sign that we're we're
finding new applications for Moors law
and it's it's only because of Moors law
that you're able to train big AI systems
because they're just so data intensive
and therefore just so compute intensive
uh to train and so there's a big debate
constantly underway in the chip industry
is Wars law finally dying um what does
it mean how would you define that but I
guess when I look across the the use
cases for compute which today the
biggest growth uh driver is is AI and
autonomous systems uh it seems to me
there's a whole lot of excitement for
the next generation of of products and
Concepts that are being developed yeah I
think that certainly is true and I guess
you know the next question is uh you
know is the next War maybe not a Chip
War but a cubit War uh what are your
thoughts there are are we going to
witness you know kind of uh really truly
exponential growth even of the exponent
in Morris law not just that it's
exponential but it's increasing in an
exponential rate will Quantum Computing
come to the rescue I think it's hard to
talk about Quantum Computing with
certainty because the industry doesn't
exist yet we've got a companies that are
in the very very early stages of trying
to create products and so we're sort of
like in the position of being in 1952 a
half a decade after the first transistor
was developed and trying to project
forward uh when the iPhone would be
created we just don't even know nor can
we really conceptualize what the iPhone
of quantum Computing will be half a
century in the future so so we're we're
speculating pretty blindly here I think
what you can say though is that if you
look at the history of classic Computing
what you find is that even the really
revolutionary changes they they happened
incrementally and so it was a decade
between the first uh invention of the
transistor of the integrated circuit
another decade between then and when big
mainframe computers became standard in
large corporations another decade after
that before the pocket calculator which
was the first real consumer product
using integrated circuits was invented
another decade after that for the PC
decade later for the iPhone and so it
was actually a very long process by
which classical Computing was applied to
all different facets of our economy and
our society and so I I I I think that
Quantum Computing will be similar it's
going to take a long time to sort out
one once we've got the technology sorted
what's the economic use case what's the
business use case and how does that
disseminate across society and when we
look at you know kind of the historical
parallels what happened as you said you
know 70 years ago now and fast forward
to today we see parallels playing out
whereas the US was engaged in a cold war
with the Soviet Union you make the case
that a decisive element of our Victory
uh if you can call it that was our
preeminence in uh in semiconductor
manufacturer and industrialization is
that all attributable to you know
capitalism versus communism in other
words that there was such a profit
incentive uh that you know the the
capitalists were destined to win and uh
if so does that not bod well and I'm not
you know obviously I'm American so I'm
going to take America's side America
First in this instance but does that
bode well for China versus America
because China is still a communist
country what what are your thoughts
there how decisive was communism versus
capitalism are historical rhyming you
know kind of analogies with what we see
with China yeah you know I think you
want to drill it down to its Basics
that's basically accurate um it it's
true that the government played a major
role in funding the first inventions
that set up the chip industry the first
chips that were produced were basically
bought by NASA or the Pentagon but if
you ask why was it that these initial
inventions which were purchased in very
small quantities by hundreds and
thousands turned into an industry that
uh now sells uh millions and millions of
units each year the answer is because
there was a huge consumer market and a
huge corporate Market that was opened
and so it it's been although it's been
the government that has funded the
initial invention it's been the civilian
Market that has funded the expansion and
has made it possible to lay down the
capital Investments that uh make it
realistic for firms to keep investing
every single year in new process
Technologies and new machines new
chemicals that's something that the
Communist World during the Cold War
didn't have they they had the military
Market they had lot lot of spending
there they had the best scientists in
the Soviet Union who were basically
conscripted into the chip industry uh
but they had a tiny market and as a
result they couldn't scale and scaling
is everything and I think that's
basically the same dilemma China finds
itself in today China is trying to build
a self-sufficient chip industry because
it doesn't want to rely on the United
States and Taiwan and Japan for
understandable reasons the problem is
that self-sufficiency means you don't
have scale China is a big country but
it's only 20% of world GDP whereas the
rest of the chip industry res selling to
80% of world GDP and if you're on the
wrong side of that equation it's just
very very hard to keep up I never like
it when an author and I've been in your
in your shoes on being interviewed you
know the podcast host ask can you
summarize the entire book you know so
that people don't have to buy it or even
listen to the audio book or or even buy
the short form no no no I am not short
form I refuse to do that but uh tsmc
plays a big role in the book and I want
to see if you can maybe approach it from
you know maybe uh maybe I'm being naive
but my first you know uh kind of stance
at this is that we have about 200 top
universities in the in the in the world
and many of them are in the United
States I mean there's thousands of great
universities but uh 200 or so have
eminent you know pre-eminent not just
photolithography um you know fabrication
facilities but they also have the
greatest scientists in the world in my
opinion my colleagues are you know
extremely brilliant why is it so hard to
have you know to Offshore tsmc and make
it you know Arizona semiconductor you
know and it seemed to be to de der risk
a lot of the you know kind of uh
existential threats that the chip
universe is being threatened by with a
potential conflict between China and the
US um why not take you know just make a
Manhattan Project like effort and
onshore into um you know maybe NATO I
don't know you can say whatever you like
but why not why is it so hard it it you
know when when when my Dean gets asked
for you know $12 million startup uh you
know to fund a new lithography um
machine facility here clean room class
you know 300 clean room they don't bulk
get it so why is it so hard especially
since Simer is located in America well
it all goes back to the question of
scale really uh so tsmc is the world's
largest chip maker because it's the
world's largest it has lower unit costs
because it can drive down the cost of
its purchases of Wafers and purchas of
chemicals but more importantly than that
it gets economies of learning because it
learns for each wafer it fabricates and
so it learns more it has more chances to
learn than any competitor so as a result
it's both uh got really impressive
economics but it's also got the best
technology uh of any other company
producing processor chips and it's been
in that position for some time and what
that means uh is that all of the world's
chip designers want to work with it and
so it's got an ecosystem that's been
built up around it whereby all the
companies that that design ships want to
work with tsmc it's got the best cost
and best technology all of the companies
that make the Machine Tools realize that
tsmc will be their biggest customer
since it's got the scale all the
companies that design the software
that's used to design chips need to make
sure their software lines up with the
smc's practices and so it's become the
platform so to speak of the entire chip
industry uh it's like the App Store you
know Apple's got iOS and everyone
designs their apps to fit in those boxes
and that's basically what tsmc is and
because it's got this immense scale if
you design a product that doesn't fit
with tsmc you miss your biggest customer
and what that means is that if you want
to replicate tsmc you got to replicate
the scale and the scale is very very
expensive to replicate so tsmc is going
to spend this year between 30 and $40
billion uh building new chip making
facilities and that's roughly as much as
the US chips Act is going to spend over
the next five years so the US government
wants to build a chip industry it's
going to spend in five years what tsmc
spends every single year and that just
shows the level of difficulty in trying
to build up that scale outside a tsmc
and tsmc hasn't been investing that much
for just one year it's been investing
huge sums for the past 30 years which is
why it's got more capacity to produce
not only the most Cutting Edge ships but
also less Cutting Edge ships than anyone
else so you know you you convince me in
the book that that the you know
advantage in the US even from its
earliest days and probably still until
now as I say with nuclear weapons
research being conducted on you know
giant doe computers that the advantage
was due to military funding so I mean uh
40 billion you know it's it's a lot of
money but it's uh you know 4% of the US
Military budget why isn't the US
military you know viewing this if it is
so and I agree with you of course
strategically why isn't there you know a
4% you know kind of a diversion of
military funding into the military just
military chips alone would seem to be a
wise investment um so what are your
thoughts there could could we see that
do we need the boogeyman like we had
with the Soviet Union or or is is china
such a such an entity or will we only
you know kind of leave it up to private
compan it seems like a great risk uh to
our national security
no I think it is and I think that's
that's one of the key reasons why
Congress a couple years ago passed the
chips act which is intended to
revitalize chip making in the US the
challenge is that although it's true the
US military needs uh cutting Ed ships
and there's ships in every F-35 fighter
for example that today can only be made
in Taiwan uh the volume that the US
military buys is small and it's true
that 40 billion is is just a small
fraction of the US defense budget but
you need 40 billion every couple of
years because a chipm facility is
Cutting Edge for a couple years and need
another one and another one after that
and so if you're sitting if you're
sitting the Pentagon you can buy a new
aircraft carrier for $10 billion or you
can buy half of a chipm facility an
aircraft carriers uh stay in operation
for half a century or a chip making
facilities Cutting Edge for just about
two years and so that's the calculus
that led the Pentagon actually to decide
very deliberately about two decades ago
not to produce its own ships anymore for
a long time they had this own this This
Confidential Fab where they could
produce all sorts of chips for the
military and intelligence agencies but
they decided it was just no longer
financially viable and it was better to
rely on Taiwan and save those money save
that money to buy other types of
equipment you have a wonderful passage
in the book you talk about chips from
Taiwan Pro provide 37% of the world's
new computing power each year two Korean
companies produce 44% of the world's
memory chips the Dutch company asml that
we talked about builds 100% of the
world's extreme ultraviolet lithography
machines without which cutting it are
simply impossible to make opec's 40%
share of world oil production looks
unimpressive by comparison and actually
I think OPEC is even decreased now I
think us is making more oil than even
Saudi Arabia now talk about the let's
let's you know do it all men love to do
secretly right let's do some War gaming
in this book War so let's say Taiwan is
attacked by CH I've used these machines
about uh 30% of the time I've tried to
use uh you know a stepper you know deep
ultraviolet etcher whatever it's down
for maintenance and there's a tech in
there and a bunny suit and and they're
working on it U these things do you know
just like an F35 I I think we had on
Hazard Lee who's a stealth fighter pilot
wrote a book uh about that U uh you know
fighter pilot we had him on the show
earlier this year and uh you know he
told me that there's about 20 hours of
maintenance for every one hour of flight
and I don't you know they're not you
know maintaining the chips but but just
all the system these machines in
incredible loving tender ha could it
even be practical in a war game scenario
for China to take out you know or take
over the island of Taiwan in about a
month they'd be out of raw materials the
machines would be down and there's only
one Soul sord they have to take over the
Netherlands too well I think that's that
is is part of the dma that if a war were
to start taiwan's chip Fabs would shut
down and they'd be basically impossible
to get started up again unless you had
the support from the Netherlands and
from the US and and from Japan it's it's
the machines which as you say require
all sorts of spare parts and expertise
that are imported into Taiwan it's also
the chemicals which largely come from
Japan and the us as well that are uh
Ultra precise hugely difficult to
produce and need to be supplied in a
regular basis so if there's a war Taiwan
shuts down I the risk for the US is that
if you ask yourself who depends more on
ships made in Taiwan is it us or is it
China the answer is very clearly us it's
you know who are tsc's biggest customers
Apple Nvidia Qualcomm AMD I haven't
listed a Chinese firm yet they're all us
companies mostly based in California and
so who would suffer more if tsmc were
shut down well that's a that's a really
complex and interesting question if you
if you actually do the economic analysis
you find that China would suffer more
because all the iPhones for example are
largely assembled in China so in pure
GDP terms China suffers more but if you
ask yourself whose political system is
is more able to sustain that type of
disruption I worry that the US is less
able to sustain it and China knows it
because China would be looking at the US
everyone in the US would be looking at
their 401ks which are largely invested
in the stock of Apple Microsoft Nvidia
Qualcomm Etc uh and they'd be cratering
and so I I think there's some concern
that China might think that although in
pure GDP terms the impact on China is
greater in fact China might be able
because of its political system to
withstand the disruption
and the US might not you mentioned
Nvidia well let's talk about them as I
understand it they're not really
manufacturing you
know you know what are the 8,000
whatever they call their their chips
it's their design and then they're
outsourced and they're made by tsmc
right that's exactly right yeah Nvidia
was actually founded uh right after tsmc
was founded they wouldn't have gotten
started up except for the fact that
their investors knew they could go to
tsmc for Manufacturing Services so
nvidia's never manufactured anything
they only design uh they partnered with
tsmc from the beginning talk about what
you see exciting in the AI space you
mentioned you know autonomous driving
and stuff like that before um Talk what
is most interesting kind of on on the
horizon not like futuristic you know
100-year Quantum you know Teslas driving
around autonomous talk about what what
excites you in the near- term for the
chips that you write so uh so
intriguingly about the key Trend in AI
has been that the most advanced AI
systems require vast increases in data
every six months so there's been great
empirical work done on the amount of
data used to train The Cutting Edge AI
system of each day and they find that
every six or 12 months there's a
doubling of data used in AI training so
faster than Mo's law of the growth and
so all of the advances in AI that we've
seen have been possible thanks to
advances in compute that have made this
type of vast training possible and so if
you want to uh project forward Trends
and AI it's it's been pretty um uh
pretty clear of the last decade you can
just project forward data training
volumes uh which means projecting
forward compute volumes and that will
give you um what the Next Generation AI
system will will basically look like and
so there's a really deep interconnection
between the types of chips that Nvidia
makes uh and the types of uh advances in
AI that we've seen I think the next
question is you know we know right now
what it takes to train an AI system high
power gpus but as we begin to deploy AI
in all sorts of devices in cars and
phones and uh indust equipment you
probably need or want different types of
chips that are optimized to that
specific domain have the right power to
electricity consumption ratio for
example uh for different domains that's
where a lot of focus is right now and
figuring out what's the right Hardware
uh specification for AI inference in
different use cases and another you know
kind of interesting um
historical uh you know kind of Excursion
you go through is is Intel obviously we
talked about Gordon Moore and and um and
his contributions uh early on and not
just techn technically but but in terms
of his you know kind of entry into the
Zeitgeist star understanding of power of
of you know things that depend on power
laws uh of which Mo's laws just W talk
about Intel and how they kind of lost I
mean I remember in the 90s you know it
was like on your computer you got a uh
you from Dell or whatever big sticker
Intel inside now it seems like they're
you know hopelessly far behind are they
going to be able to catch shop or you
know are they going to have to Pivot
into doing some other you software
services or data storage or something
like that will they get away or come
back to their Roots well you know one of
the big problems that Intel has faced is
that that the PC market which as you say
used to be a real growth driver has
slowed now nobody knows what kind of
chips in their PC because it doesn't
matter our chips are good enough PCS run
they're not exciting anymore uh and so
Intel still dominates that market but
it's just the less exciting Market not
growing anymore then Intel in the data
center which is Intel's other big Market
has lost out to companies like Nvidia it
was behind the curve when it came to Ai
and so the most recent data suggests
that three out of four dollars spent in
data centers past year went to Nvidia
and Intel and AMD have just been
competing for the remainder so that's
that's a a real challenge for until they
got to turn around but the second issue
is that they fell behind tsmc when it
came to manufacturing technology they
they do both design and Manufacturing
and and they've been lagging tsmc for
the past couple years now it looks like
they've got a chance of catching up to
tsmc we'll see if they do uh but their
aim is to catch up by 2025 this is CH
18a exactly yeah yeah exactly and right
now they say they're on schedule and so
uh it may be just as good as what tsmc
has but then they've got to match that
manufacturing capacity with designs that
people want to buy and theyve they're
right up against both AMD and Nvidia
right now for both PCS and data centers
and it's going to be very tough
competition another uh kind of uh
interesting take in the book that I came
away with is the importance of uh of
immigration to the all chip story um
obviously this involves uh cooperation
and and sometimes competition between
different nations different philosophies
um I I read an article one recently um
that talked about how uh much the
tightening of curbs on AI exports to
China is going to you know really impact
not only uh sales in the bottom line for
NVIDIA uh but also so like recruiting of
talent both in both directions maybe um
talk about immigration has it been you
know net good and and with limitations
on H1B visas many of my students and
post talks and and so forth have
benefited from that uh both in Chi from
China and Southeast Asia uh talk about
that how how uh how is immigration
figure into the Chip War my view is that
immigration has been Central to us
success over the past uh 75 years if if
you look at all of the key turning
points in the chip industry you can find
immigrants as part of the story for
example the the eight Engineers who
founded Fairchild semiconductor which is
the kind of first Silicon Valley startup
and the chip space two of them were were
foreign born so that's 25% uh right out
the bat if you look at the successive
Intel uh it was about Gordon Moore and
Bob noise but it was also about Andy
Grove who was the longtime CEO who was
born as andras Grove when he was born in
Budapest before moving to uh New York as
a as a refugee and and the same is true
today look at jenon Wong CEO of Nvidia
born in Taiwan before growing up uh in
Kentucky uh and so I think there's
there's uh a very strong pattern it's
it's basically as strong a correlation
as we got with Mo's law uh when it comes
to IM immigrants playing a huge role in
the chip industry and it really is a a
challenging issue today because as you
say as as the US tries to split the chip
World in two a China Focus world and a
rest of the world uh sphere uh it's
forcing people to chose sides and so
there's actually been regulations the US
has passed that say neither US citizens
nor green card holders can work with
certain Chinese firms and there's been
reports that certain green card holders
have decided to give up the green card
to keep working with these banned firms
and so it has had a direct impact but I
think in the long run the the US has
still got a pretty strong position uh
Visa China if you look at the the net
immigration flows there a whole lot of
people coming from China to the US and a
much smaller number going from the US or
other countries uh to China um but you
say the complexity and the small numbers
of h-1bs make it more difficult than it
probably should be being of China uh the
same kind of geopolitical strategist
Peter Zan uh I don't know if you're
familiar with him but he he's he's sort
of a America I would say America bull
but he he basically is claiming that you
know China's on the verge of collapse
their demographics are horrible I've you
know pointed out I had on Mo Gat who
worked at at Google X for a long time
and and uh is is a great writer and
thinker and we talk talked about you
know how even even if it's uh true that
they're you know going to lose a net net
replacement of 300 million people
they're still going to have over a
billion people you know uh for the next
50 60 years and there's no chance of
America catching them perhaps India
already surpasses them but uh what do
you make of Zan's kind of analysis that
you know China's essentially you've
written you know several books in the
USSR and they're they're collapse and
and Putin and and gorbachov do you see
any parallels are they imminently about
to collapse as as Peter my claim or or
do you feel actually we're that may be
you know a scop that you they're
perpetrating to make us underestimate
how powerful they may actually be if you
look at the history of authoritarian
systems like China what you find is that
they always look pretty strong until the
moment before they collapse and it's
very very hard to predict the moment a
brittle system just pops apart and so
when I look at China right now things
look pretty stable but I think we've got
to uh recognize that the Soviet Union
looked pretty stable in 1989 too and
then two years later it was gone now I
don't think that's a prediction I
wouldn't bet on that if I were uh
betting on China's future but I I do
think Peter's right to say that China's
got a lot of real challenges the
demographics the economics the
confrontation not just with the us but
with all of its key trading partners
Japan Korea Taiwan India uh if if you
were to you know arrive from Mars and
say which country would you rather be I
don't think you'd pick China and we are
just to Pivot back to some of the
Personalities in the book so talk about
Jensen hor he's sort of this iconic
clastic figure shows up at a in a you
know biker jacket has a huge tattoo on
his uh on his body kind of like a like a
an Elvis kind of cult-like Guru
following how much of that is to sort of
uh uh is to blame for their success
maybe and then uh do you do you believe
that you know kind of this this cult of
personality is warranted I mean is he
that a visioner I haven't researched
beyond what you provided in the book his
description which I think is wonderful
but I'll talk about him as as a person
as a leader as a Visionary where where
do you see how he fits in in the in the
Grand Story um of of chips but also of
innovators and the kind of Silicon
Valley uh tradition you know what I I
think he deserves all of the credit that
he's given if if you look at what Nvidia
has done it is a series of extraordinary
bats that looked wild and Reckless when
when they were made and turned out uh to
be absolutely Central to advances in
Computing when Nvidia was founded and
Jensen was one of the three co-founders
they co-founded it in a Denny's in San
Jose so it's this classic kind of
Silicon Valley startup uh story they
their their only product was to produce
Graphics chips for computers they did
that pretty successfully for 15 years
and then they heard uh in the early
2000s stories of PhD students at
Stanford and Berkeley and elsewhere
using their chips for machine learning
and Ai and they realized that basically
the same designs that would were good
for graphics were also good for training
AI systems and so they began pouring
irresponsibly large sums of money into
building out a software ecosystem
around the idea of using their Graphics
chips for AI at the time they were
criticized uh for being hugely wasteful
betting out an industry that didn't
exist Wall Street was furious at all the
money they were spending and until last
year it looked like it might not pan out
uh but over the past 12 months as we've
uh just seen what uh large language
models in particular can do and realize
that basically all of them are trained
on nvidia's ships uh every tech company
in the world has been scrambling to get
their hands on products that Nvidia
creat and I think Jensen deserves a
whole lot of credit for seeing that
Trend nearly two decades in advance of
everyone else and the important part is
he only saw the trend he was able to
stick with it spend a whole lot of money
building it up when most people said it
was a crazy idea hey friends it's me
back again with a request for you to win
a chunk not of a silicon chip but of a
meteorite a real 4.3 billion year-old
fragment of the early solar system and
all you have to be entered to win each
month is join my mail list at
banking.com list when you do so you'll
be entered to win one of these chunks of
space Schmutz the 4 billion year old
chunk of our solar system maybe not as
Hightech as those silicon chips that
we've been talking about today with
Chris Miller but nevertheless unique
interesting and fascinating I'll send
you information about meteor showers and
all sorts of other goodies and how you
can watch them so join my mission and if
you have a doedu email address you'll be
automatically entered to win and you'll
automatically receive a chunk of space
dust now back to the episode but before
you forget visit briank king.com list to
join my mailing list you'll receive the
hottest news from around the stem
Universe once each week on Mondays
thanks back to the episode I finish up
with a couple questions both in some way
related to cryptocurrency to bitcoin
it's been rumored that you know
something like half the compute you know
power on Earth is dedicated to uh is
dedicated to uh Bitcoin mining uh by
itself and then there's you know
whatever 20,000 other alternative coins
and and networks and so forth I had on
Michael sailor extremely bullish about
it and you know his basic thesis is that
you know Bitcoin is stored energy and
that's the um that's the irreducible
kind of UND dilutable perfect form of
money etc etc I'm not getting into the
bit Bitcoin thesis although if you have
any hot tips for our audience let us
know Chris but uh but in uh in reality
the Staggering amount if it's true the
half the world's energy is basically
dedicated computer compute power and
something like the equivalent of of a uh
you know all the US nuclear powerered
carrier battle groups uh worth of worth
of energy is devoted to Bitcoin mining
uh which is significant fraction talk
about you know the the prospects for uh
for you know savings or or maybe the
pixon shovel layer uh of maybe the
energy side of of compute uh because you
know it cost energy to compute even to
erase a bit you know in at a fundamental
physics of information level cost energy
and so and it contributes to waste heat
and waste energy which contributes to
you know the use of fossil fuels
primarily so talk about how do we
integrate energy into it how should we
think about things like cryptocurrencies
and their and their you know I wouldn't
say Monopoly but large Demand on compute
power and energy requirements well it's
absolutely right that this is a a key
challenge the industry faces and really
has faced from the beginning if if you
look at why the first decision was made
to move from computers based on discrete
transist to computers based on
integrated circuits lower power
consumption was a key driver and so the
industry has been driven forward by its
ability to produce more power efficient
compute uh that's been a key demand from
customers from the earliest days and so
if you ask yourself why is it that every
year smartphone companies pay a lot of
money to dsmc to give them a better
smartphone chip is because the power to
compute ratio tends to get better on a
pretty regular basis and there's
trade-offs more power versus more
performance and uh the the the
efficiency laws that dictate that power
consumption should get better over time
have been performing much less well in
recent decades than they did in the
early stages uh but there's a huge Focus
underway right now in finding um finding
ways to make it all more efficient
because as you say uh it it is
fundamentally a key input to compute and
if our demand for compute is basically
infinite I think it basically is our
supply of power is not and so we've got
to find ways to keep economizing on on
on electricity usage yeah my favorite
you kind of thing to think about quantum
computers is that they're extremely good
at solving you know what's called a Gran
for a Quantum Computing system they're
very good solipsistically at looking at
the underlying quantum mechanical
equations and those are governed by
things called Arians and and they
they're very good at at finding these
minimal energy surfaces and doing path
integrals and all these things that
Fineman talked about way back when but
they're not you know yet found as you
said scalability a practic consumer you
know uh viable consumer um option Etc
but my favorite you know kind of future
optimistic you know polyon view is that
you quantum computers are going to
figure out a way to get uh High TC
superc conductivity which would then
reduce the energy draw on compute and
almost every other thing that we depend
on for our modern technological World
well Chris this has been a phenomenal
interview I thank you for your time I
can't uh resist asking you one final
question I usually ask when I'm speaking
with a Nobel Prize winner so that shows
you the esteem I have for you um this
podcast is called into the impossible
and it derives its name from Sir Arthur
C Clark who said the only way of
determining the limits of the possible
is to transcend them and go into the
impossible you're a professor you've
written bestselling books you know one
of the FTS finalist best best book of
the year um give me uh 20 seconds of
advice you have 20 seconds with your
20-year-old version of yourself uh what
do you tell him what do you tell him to
give him the confidence to do as you've
done to go into the impossible well I
think you know it's it's a hard question
for historians to ask because our job is
to look at things that have already been
done so we already know that know that
they're possible I think if there's one
thing that I I guess I've learned it's
it's about the the need to try to
connect different disciplines together I
me I when I started I had no knowledge
of electrical engineering or physics or
Material Science or anything uh just a
background in economic history but it
turns out that just applying that
background to an industry like
semiconductors can produce a lot of uh
pretty extraordinary stories and unlock
a new way of seeing technology and so
that that I think is is what I hope made
the book pretty interesting and if
there's a lesson that I that I drew from
the research that's it uh I can't resist
asking uh one one final question it's
prompted by Richard feeman who is in
some ways a f founder of nanotechnology
a famous famous paper you probably read
it called plenty of room at the bottom
and he starts off that uh he says I I
imagine experimental physicists must
often look with Envy at a man like Cam
and OMS who discovered a field like low
temperature superc conductivity which
seems to be bottomless in which one can
go down and down and down such a man is
then the leader and has some temporary
Monopoly on a scientific Adventure I see
a lot of that in this book it's told so
wonderfully and if I could close with
one last question to you again inspired
by Sir Arthur C Clark the namesake
generator of this podcast after all and
uh he said that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic and I like to think feeman
answered that question once he said what
what statement contains the most
information about the physical Universe
in the fewest words and he said
basically the atomic hypothesis that
everything's made of little atoms
whirling around and uh and bonding and
combining together what do you see as
the most magical form of technology is
it the demic conductor chip is there
something else that we didn't get to
discuss what form of technology is most
akin to Magic in your opinion we talked
a bit about the the asml lithography
machines that uh that convert tiny balls
of tin into light at just the right we
wavelength 13.5 nmet to bounce off the
flattest mirrors in the world and atch
Tiny circuits on on the chip inside of
your iPhone to to me understanding how
that machine worked and understanding
how every day of my life I relied on the
chips that It produced that that was
really a a magical Discovery it's still
sort of a a shock that machines like
that work on a on a regular basis
absolutely well Chris uh where can
people find you and learn more about
your work and your other books fantastic
my my website is Christopher miller.net
Chris thank you so much for your
valuable time I uh enjoyed it very much
I hope we can speak again in the future
maybe meet up someday great thank you
Bri